[MUSIC PLAYING]
JULIA LALLA-MAHARAJH: Last year, I volunteered
in Ethiopia.
And one of the things I saw there, female
genital mutilation, has
completely changed the path of my life.
I realized I couldn't look away from this
urgent issue.
So I came back to London and volunteered with
an organization.
And a friend sent me a link to the YouTube
Debates saying someone with
a urgent human rights cause had to go to Davos.
And I thought, this is got to be it.
So why send me to Davos?
Because I want to ask those innovative and
intrepid world leaders to
put their hearts and minds and power behind
ending FGM.
I've just found out that I am going to Davos.
Since I won, I've been doing a video diary
every day and really just
trying to raise awareness of the basics of
this very complex issue.
So what is FGF?
It's very simply the removal of a girl's external
genitals, the
clitoris, the labia, and in severe cases,
the wound that's left is sewn
up, so there's only a tiny hole left.
I'm just pleased the day is here, actually,
because it's been a lot of
prep to get to this point.
It's night one in Davos and as you can see,
it's absolutely beautiful.
My belief is that issues like this can't stay
on the margins, that they
really have to be debated at the highest levels.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL CLINTON: I'll follow up.
Bless you.
JULIA LALLA-MAHARAJH: I'm really delighted
I entered this competition.
Who would have thought ten days later I would
go from my kitchen table
to Davos?
But let's not be complacent.
This is just a few days at Davos.
There's so much more to be done.
There's still 3 million girls a year being
cut.
So what can we do together today to help do
something about this?
[MUSIC PLAYING]